Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
And welcome back to Leeethe or whatever the hell you pronounce that is.
I don't think I'm ever gonna find out, and right now it dun't matter.
That's not food, that was a can of paint and I can't eat that.
That's not gonna help me in any capacity.
THIS IS CLOSED! (Nah shit)
The illusion of choice that I last left off with was nothing
Absolutely dick-diddley
Man, this hallway reminds me of something.
If anyone watched the uhh, original Amnesia reaction compilation,
like, the opening scene from that kinda is like this hallway.
I dunno, I-- I constantly..
I-- I know I CONSTANTLY go back to Amnesia The Dark Descent,
but I can't help *inhale* but make the comparisons
Like, I draw back  from all the Amn--  like-- the inst--
OH GOD DAMMIT！
BOTH OF 'EM?!
IT WAS BOTH AN ILLUSION OF CHOICE?
This is a bunch o' bullshit!
But I-- I always draw back on like, my prior experiences in
in a horror,
and I always looked back on like,
what I, what I've done in the past,
and how.. how that's effected me...
Okay....
Well, I don't think I can go back-- OH HEY!
Thanks for holdin' that up for me! (You're welcome!)
You're such a nice guy. (Thank you! ^_^)
*DEEP INHALE*
So like, when I look at horror games,
I always have to compare them to what I've done in the past,
because that's just where my mind goes automatically
when I play these games
I go back to the good and the bad experiences that I've had throughout time.
And not saying that this is in any way bad!
This is actually been very good and very intriguing and--
That's an odd bloodstain to have on a couch!
.... Alrighty then...
OoOo~ multiple notes
Reads Note: "Diary of the Affliction,
We already encountered our first set back. Patient three is silently left our world for the next."
"May he find peace for wherever he may be. Dr. Godfread will be preforming necropsy on the assumption that we will learn more about this illness, which has become known locally as the Affliction."
"The symptoms are unlike anything the staff has seen. Some of the patients show a surprising degree of apathy, almost as if they have been heavily sedated."
"In light of this, the dosages of sedatives and painkillers administered to the patients have been reduced, as we will still want them to be able to communicate and cooperate with us."
"As per usual I will closely keep an eye on the progression of their symptoms."
MARK: Let's see...
"We've already encountered a setback..."
Is that all the same one of these?
Oh, apparently so.....
Okay, so this is probably the lab area that the guy was working in.
Oooh~
S'CUSE ME
*chair clanks*
I can't believe I don't get to use my hands anymore,
I just automatically wrenching things out with my psychic powers.
Reads note: "The care and study of the patients has become quite the nuisance. Attempts at washing have been met with violence and they have become increasingly uncooperative, unwilling to partake in our examinations."
"Horrific disfigurements are starting to appear, leading me to the conclusion that this Affliction will not be cured with common medicine. It has shown to be progressively ineffective in treating this illness and it's symptoms..."
MARK: OKAY, so it's hopeless
And then you started experimenting in worse and worse ways
and discovered that they would be perfect candidates--
WABOOSKY
*sad thump*
*RANDOM MARK-GRUNTS*
There we go, that's a little better *laughing*
OH IS THAT A KUH-BAAB?!
OH IS THAT A KUH-BAAAAB?!
OoOo, it's moldable kuh-babs!
I'm sure they're not spoiled! (Of course not Mark.)
(They have been there for God knows how long and you eat it. Good job.)
Yuuuum~
nom NOM nom
*laughing* Oh boy!
Eugh
I ate 'em stick and all...
A'right..
Nothing here.
Why did I come back here?
Nothing here for me besides the keh-baaabs.
And a bunch of un-openable lockers.
Filing cabinets anyway.
Weeeell this was useless.
I made a bit of music and I made a lot a' noise.
Pretty much the summary of my entire existence. (Well that's odd..)
Alright. Hebeh!
*Ominous music*
Hi...
Ohhhhh this is not lookin' good
Whenever I go into a lab area and there's a lot of blood and dead bodies...
They even wrapped this one up!
HEHAHA
They wrap 'em up!
Probably because they were afraid of the... uh... affliction being spread.
Reads note: "In great... de- sadness I have taken notice of Dr. Gottfried's passing."
"It appears that he has been beaten to death by an enraged patient..."
"His skull cracked open and his face beaten to a pulp!"
"I still find it rather difficult to believe this has been the work of a mere man."
"With bare hands, no less."
"They have informed me that we w- will be relocated  to a more suitable working place today..."
"We will have to be cautious, because the patient is still at large!"
MARK: And boy, howdy is it a large patient!
Holy shit that's probably the guy th' they're talking about already.
Reads note: "The others have left, but I will stay behind. I must!"
"Constraining the subjects has been proven to be difficult without assistance,"
"But the resonators appear to work."
"I have discovered a safer way to use the extract in a very potent, restorative concoction."
"As a result of the new refining process the tincture has taken on a distinctive red hue which I find strangely mesmerizing."
"I have administered this medicine to half the remaining subjects in hoping that it will cure them of the affliction and return them to sanity."
"Only time can tell."
"Even though the subjects are showing signs of improvement, their mental state is still deteriorating."
"I do not feel too well. I think I might have fallen ill."
MARK: Well!
I was thinking that that guy was- like- gonna be going down
a spiral-- downwards spiral of, uh- of insanity himself.
And it seems like he might just starting to take that
But not-- eugh...
Eugh! I don't like that!
Eugh!
That is every type of bad!
Oh I'm a - I'm approaching some bad parts aren't I?
Reads note (fast): "As requested what follows is a list of all the members and staff"
"and their age from the science facilities for reference persons:"
"Bill Paradompulus"
"Dr. Aaron P. Gottfried"
"Kendrick, Kovacz, Roscenburg, Aldner, Miller."
Okay.
So that's just a reference of everybody in here.
Yup, that wouldn't open. Would it.
*Markiplier noises*
Okay.. is there anything in here?
Okay....
*More Markiplier noises*
*Markimoo making fart noises*
Okay got those moving al-
*glowing & suspenseful music*
AGH
WHY?!
HOW?!
He's not in here is he?!
Where is he?!
OH! Hiiii
Oh, you're - are you different?
OOOOH! Oh, good! Why does he have a read glowy on his back?
*grunts*
Okay is he coming here?
AM I SUPPOSED TO HIDE?!
Oh shit! oh fuck! oh shit! oh fuck! *bumping into boxes*
AHHH!
I've done bad!
There's nowhere to hide in here!! (Yes there is.)
Uh shit.
He better not be comin' this way. I'mma have a jack-slap ready for him.
*monster growls*
*whispers* box hide me! Chair hide me! Stool you're not chair, you'll never be a chair! You're just a stool.
Oh shit, okay. I think it's fine.
Reads note: "The novel type of treatment with lethaum appears to be quite effective, the subjects are now recovering physically as well as mentally,"
"although scarring and external disfigurements do not seem to heal regardless of the dosage."
"One might consider this reasonable after all their bodies have been through. They have become calm and obedient,"
"but seem to stay apathetic regardless of external stimuli. Recently I have noticed that I have been getting splitting headaches whenever I am near one of the Resonators."
"It might be malfunctioning, I will have to turn some of them off for further inspection."
MARK: NO! You're just becoming inflected with the INFLECTION.
Okay, so...
*Markimoo_lookaround.exe*
OH! Noo, goddammit. *proceeds to mutter*
*clanking* ... HELLO~
OOOOOHHH!! OHHHHH!! O MAH GOSH!!
I never would've noticed that!
Holy shit. Wow, I did not notice that at all. I don't know why.
I just had not thought to look down, holy shit. (Like with the bear traps.)
EWW! Hi! *chuckles* well what a convenient dumping pit for all you surgical failures! OOOHHHH!
OH THERE'S MORE! How delightful!
Oh boy I'm so gl- *noises scare markimoo*
*buzzing*
*Markimoo_IsSpook.exe*
Okay...
*suspenseful music*
Alright
Okay
Cool, thank you for that.
That was cool, glad you did that!
Wonderful time we're having here ಠ⌣ಠ
For some fucking reason. Ah good yes, let me check this door first.
Oh good, yes stuff, and things and food. Nothing there but a little bit of food with keep me going.
Keep me warm at night. So this is where the monsters w- *clank* this is where the monster was walking through.
Is he going to be takin' a nap over here? Takin' a little beddiby.
Reads note: "A man from the village barged, begging me to save the woman in his arms. What a gory mess she was lying there on my table,"
"not often do you see a victim of such cruelty. Many parts of her body were maimed beyond recognition."
"She was baring a child at the time and if I was to save them both I had to get it out as soon as possible. In the end I was not able to save what remained of her left hand."
"I think it is only reasonable to make full use of this opportunity that has presented itself to me. After all, I had him sign away his rights to the child so I can continue my research,"
"because I suspect this child holds secret vitally important to my scientific endeavors."
MARK: How and why and what?!
Note: "The restorative tincture has proven itself to be of vital importance, it would have been impossible to keep both mother and child alive otherwise."
"After treating the mother's broken mind with Lethaum she has become calm and remain to be so. Although I suspect she will never return to her former self after what she has been through."
MARK: Well that's a little bizarre. Next thing you're going to tell me is that child is the me.
That would make some semblance of sense giving that I have been sent away,
*creaking from doors*
and that my "father" and my real father sent me away long ago.
It would make sens -- eugh...
Am I gonna take another piss break? Is that what I'm over here? Ew.
🎵Never trust the bathrooms in a--🎵
Ooohh. Hi buddy
Don't mind me. Don't mind me.
Thank you, I appreciate your sacrifice,
for making sure that got to me.
*Clank*
*Clank [x2]*
Oh boy. Hello.
OH NO! Another piss break?
Probably. Ha Ha. Good. Ya.
Everyone needs a little breather once and a while. ಠ⌣ಠ
*Pissing sounds*
*Pissing sounds* Great!...
Hello?
Hi
Oh OH
Just barely open can't quite get through though
Not enough pow-errr
Haha The exit is so tantalizingly close
Its must be like a game the developer's playing with us
Just because they're like "Oh here is another exit that you can't get to, HAHA HEHA HOHOHO"
Okay thats been uh, thats been roped off
Thats open, get outta the way
Why does it forces me to do that?
I can't pick 'em up with my own bare hands
SHEESHKEEBAABS!!!
BLIP
Okay
[ Reads the note on the screen ]
Oh GOSH everyone's starvin' again and then everyone's turning into horrible monsters but why do I have to do all the work?!
This is BULLSHIT!
I hate my life!
Which is about to end
Okay..
Anything else in here, other than just people bitchin' and moanin'
About their state of the kitchen of here
Huh
Bitchin' in the kitchen'
With.. DINA!
Okay.
[ Reads whatever is on screen but fails ]
[ Deep breath ]
[ Reads whatever is on the screen ]
[ Another deep breath ]
Who wrote that?
And why and how.
Okay, I guess I'll go this way then.
See I can't-
EUGHHHH
EUGH
GEUGH
Man my arms are too weak
I mean my psychic powers are great and all
But my are just limp noodles
Alright, anyway
Anybody here?
Any sheeshkababs?
Any food, drink? No okay..
Down this- ooo hello
[ Markimoo reading what's on screen ]
HEHEH
Don't promise me a good time and then not deliver!
Alright, here we go.
Well there's gotta be a way
to open the hatch then
If it's sealed up
that means it can be un-sealed a-somehow
Maybe with psycho-powers?! :D
No?  :(
Hm...
Well there's gotta be a way-- Oh!
The switch right below the sign!
Huh that would be-- That w- That would be.....
*beeps and ominous noises*
*chain pulling*
Why'd that sound like a voice
and not necessarily anything else
Woooa that's aah
Oh... well!
I just wanted to leap down and be ready
to attack anything that came at me!
Come at me, bros!
You ♪suuuuuuuuck♪
Ehlllo :(
Hidey hidey hidey ho
Huuhuh
Huuhuhu
Uuh
Oh
Hidey hidey hidey ho
Please don't come at me bro :(((
[BARS]
Okay so that's...
..What was that?
W-well that's.. that's weird (is it?)
Who's playing a harpsichord down here?
*gurgles the first word* Well that's not a good sound (never is)
Hokay!
Hokay-- oh!
This is where I prepare to get soaked!
Alright! My body is ready! Oh...
Is there anything down here?
No! I just decided to take a dip in the piss water
for absolutely no raisin.
Okay good. Okay
So there's gotta be something to do with that uh..
That valve.... but I don't know where to put the valve
So if it's not over here...
Oh. Oh! How did I miss this??
What? Really?!
How did I miss that?!
Aw man I don't know how.
THIS is where I get soaked! Okay!
Ah good yes, love it
*makes fun of the character's gasping* *dying fishiplier*
I was down there for half a second, man!
*gasp* A new world record!! *gasp*
*mrng*
Boh god no!
OBSTACLES
*hr bleh*
Okay. So where are we now?
Oh do I have to pull these off?
No I can't even move 'em-- Oh!
This way! Obviously the way without boards in it.
Huh that'd be smart
Okay where am I...
Uh oh that don't sound good *is drowning*
Oh god that's not good
Help! Ohh help
There we go okay we're fine
Alrighty then! Not too bad, only some minor cases of drowning
I mean jeez, it was only a few seconds
Ah! Eugh...
Ah
It didn't get any better when the lights got on
Still a lotta dead *CLUNK* *sharp inhale*
*pained exhale*
FFfuck those things okay?
Seriously. Juuuuuuuust
fuck those things
They're only there...
To be cheap scaaares
And they get me
EVERY GODDAMN TIME
*voice cracks* Ffuucking bear traps
Okay I see like the lever
the broken off.. uh wheel. I need the
other wheel
I need to go get the wheel and
bring it all the way over here
but I don't know how to do that because
I don't na nave enough mmmMENTAL JUICe
Oh wait
There's another one here okay.
I can't pick it up!
That's so stupid
No not you!
'k get over here
*hyup*
*cowiplier* You're comin' with meeee
Oh! It doesn't consume extra juice to hold it
Which is weird considering it seems like
I'm exerting a lot of force here.
*hehbleh*
Good! I did it!
And water! Great!
*hehdebeh*
*heuyeugh*
This one works really well!
That other one was a sassy bitch! This one
is the one!
Why didn't I just pop it off of that one
and then move it over to the other?
I don't know what's happening (do you ever) but it sounds big
Okay here we go!
I don't think that was enough time
So I need to hit it
I don't-- I need to hit it, it'll automatically
go and theeeen I sprint for it
Okay I got it
Derr
Here we go
*bedaladela*
*ahdeladela* Hidey hidey hidey ho
Go go go go go go go
Fucking go you fucking bro
Oh jeez
*ee ehe* Yes! Yes!
Yes! Great success!
Now can I please go up the ladder.
Please?  :(
Sir?
Ma'am?
What?!
There we go! Jeez
I thought I was gonna be stuck there
Alright. Get outta there.
Alright whatta ya got back here?
Whatta ya hidin' here??
Anything? Food? Water? I'm desperate.
Alright, nothin' there
*hedeh*
*heBRUHfe* Ohh jeez it's dark...
Oooh can't see a thing
Oooh no light
Ooh it's just emptiness...
Okay nothing over there..
Aackkk
Okay
[ Hits barrel ]
Alright...
What else we got?
Ooo it is so dark down here
And quiet too.
That's never a good sign
Eeeugh
Daark and QUIET!
Dark and quiet...
Aand I gotta go farther.. Ooo I caught a glimpse of something I didn't like. heheh
I caught a glimpse of a baddd
What was that?
Okay I'll go down, Oooh no
Eugh, hi.. welcome..
OH! It was nothing. I thought I saw something over here!
I thought I saw a horrifying figure in the darkness
Ah geez
Ahh..
Okay, Everything is fine I suppose
OOHOHO! That's a comforting sign!
Hello friend! How you doin'?
Helloo
Come on now, come on...
Play with me..
Eeeugh
Okay.
Aha! Good..
Yess.. verryy goooodd
Okay so wut was the point of coming in here?
Doesn't seem like there's a whole lot of anything.
Nope, that one's close and this one's empty.
Fattalotta good did this anybody
HIBIBYA
Ooooh ahhh
Smart smart smart, smart smart smart!
Knew there had to be a reason!
Okay.
So this goes somewhereee..
Okay verryy 💡 bright 💡
Okay, hold this sa-
(*gasps in shock)
Fucking! Cock with you bitches
Good God!
Everywhere!
WHY???
Why are you such sassy sacks of crap???
Ugh
This liquid which now emanates with a warm amber glow,
has undergone additional refinement with an electrical flux
and is starting to show some remarkable characteristics.
So far I have been able to apply this Catalyst to the machines
that are almost running up dry.
Elevating the pressure to unexpected levels,
greatly increasing their power outputs.
This Catalyst will prove to be most useful to further my research.
Thaaaanks, Doctor Rosenbergh....
I see you're starting on your descent to MADNESS
Maybe, maybe . Maybe he's just a good guy
Maybe it's just like my bias towards people.